حياكم الله تصوروا لو ان احدكم رجل اعمال
او سيده اعمال على درجه كبيره من الثراء
وتريدون الحصول على جنسيه وجواز سفر
يمنحكم الحق في ان تتجول وتقيموا في مختلف
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الامر كان يمكن ان
يتحقق بكل بساطه في قبرص كل المطلوب هو
استثمار مليونين و500 الف يورو في قطاع
العقارات
ويصبح الانسان او الشخص مواطن قبرسي كامل
الحقوق المواطنه هناك هذا هذا ما كان
سائدا في الجزيره العائمه شرقي
المتوسط تحقيق استقصائي لفريق التحقيقات
هنا في شبكه الجزيره كشف ما تعانيه منظومه
القوانين في البلاد من ثغرات دخل منها
هاربون من القانون ومدان بجرائم لعل اقلها
خطوره غسل الاموال نحن نتحدث عن غسل اموال
فقط نتحدث عن غسل هويه
بعد اسابيع فقط من بث تحقيق الجزيره قررت
السلطات القبرصيه التراجع والغاء البرنامج
المشبوه لمنح ما يعرف بالجواز
الذهب رغم الحماسه التي صاحبت الترويج لها
على امتداد سنوات قررت السلطات القبرصيه
الغاء العمل بجوازات السفر هذا تسمى مجازا
الجوازات الذهبيه وهي كذلك فعلا فقمه
الواحد منها لا تقل عن مليونين و500 الف
يورو يدفعها الراغب في الحصول على الجواز
مقابل استثمار غالبا ما يكون في مجال شراء
العقارات ويحصل بذلك على الجنسيه القبرصيه
وعلى حق التنقل الحر في دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي ال7 حتى دون ان يكون مجبرا على
الاستقرار في قبرص
لم يقدم المتحدث باسم الحكومه القبرصيه
تفاصيل كثيره عن اسباب الغاء برنامج
استثمار انتفع به اكثر من 400 الف شخص ودر
على البلاد مليارات من اليورو منذ ان راى
النور عام 2007 اكتفى المسؤول الحكومي
القبرصي بالحديث عن وجود نقاط ضعف طويله
الامد وانتهاك واستغلال لبنود برنامج
الاستثمار الخاص بالجوازات
الذهبيه
لكن اللافته ان الخطوه القبرصيه جاءت بعد
ساعات من بث وحده الاستقصاء في شبكه
الجزيره تحقيقا جديدا هو الثاني في ظرف
شهرين كشفت فيه بالوثائق والادله انتهاك
برنامج الجوازات الذهبيه للقانون القبرصي
وحتى للقوانين الدوليه فاثبت انه شمل
مجرمين ومدان ومتورط في عمليات غسل اموال
من بين مواطني 70 دوله بعضهم نافذون دون
ان يضطر العديد منهم للكذب او اخفاء سجله
الاجرامي عن المسؤولين
القبسه هذه اللقطات تعد اخطر ما كشفه
تحقيق شبكه الجزيره يظهر هنا مسؤولون قبرص
بينهم رئيس البرلمان
[موسيقى]
ونائبه هنا محاوله لمساعده شخص عرف نفسه
بانه عميل ينوب عن شخصيه لها سجل اجرامي
وترغب في الحصول على الجواز الذهبي لم يكن
هذا الشخص سوى مراسل شبكه الجزيره وقد صور
كل ما دار بواسطه كاميرا خفيه في اول رد
فعل له نفى رئيس البرلمان القبرصي ان يكون
قد انتهك القانون واعلن تنحيه لحين
استكمال التحقيقات بلغه الصحافه والاعلام
يمكن الحديث عن وجبه استقصائيه دسمه نجحت
شبكه الجزيره في اعدادها ورفعت فيها عاليا
سقف ما يمكن ان يحققه الاستقصاء الصحفي
حين يدافع عن حق المواطن في المعلومه
والشفافيه فهي لم تقتصر على فضح ممارسات
شخصيات قابله للاستبدال بل كشفت المنظومه
المفسده برمتها ودفعت ولو بصفه غير مباشره
نحو الغائها وسطت الضوء مجددا على ظاهره
متفشيه بصفه متفاوته لا في قبرص فحسب بل
في العديد من
الدول لمناقشه هذا الملف معنا من ن قسيه
ديفيد هارسون مراسل شبكه الجزيره وعضو في
وحده التحقيقات فيها وكذلك من بروكسل معنا
لور بريو محللات السياسات في منظمه
الشفافيه الدوليه اهلا بكم فقط نشير الى
اننا حاولنا استضافه عدد من الشخصيات في
قبرص يعني سواء كانوا محللين سياسيين او
صحفيين ولكنهم او مسؤولين حتى ولكنهم
جميعا رفضوا المشاركه في هذا
النقاش على
العموم يعني ديفيد اعرف انك اليوم تستقبل
في نيقوسيا كبطل ولكن الصوره كانت مختلفه
تماما قبل اسابيع
كانوا الفريق كله تهم بانه يصطاد في الماء
العكر يعمل على تشويه صوره قبرص ويخدم
تركيا ما الذي
تغير 180
درجه اعتقد ان جواب على ذلك بسيط جدا
اعتقد ان التغيير هو ان الناس شاهدوا
البرنامج الوثائقي فعندما وصلوا في اليوم
الذي نشر فيه هذا البرنامج هذا الوثائق
كان تصلنا تهجمات كثيره واقتراحات بان هذه
مؤامره سياسيه عذرا هناك كلاب تحيط به
ولكن نستطيع ان نستمر ولكن ما ان شاهد
الناس هذا الفيلم الوثائقي غيروا ارائهم
وبدا الناس يدركون بان الادله اللي
قدمناها قويه
ودامغة وهذه الادله ويقبلونها طبعا
وشاهدوا بانها كانت نتيجه تحقيق واسع ولكن
الراي العام تغير بشكل كبير الى حد انهم
راوا ان الادله قويه بما يكفي
لتكون لكي تحون
عملنا ديفيد يعني تقول انهم تاثروا بما
شاهدوا رغم ان الموضوع ليس جديدا الموضوع
اثير من قبل يعني محطات مثل رويترز ووسائل
اخرى انتم في الوثائق الذي نشرته ما
الذي يعني توصلتم اليه مختلف عن ما كان
يثيره الاخرون
وكيف كلاف تعوي الى جانب ارجو تكرار
السؤال نعم كنت اسالك يعني رويترز وبعض
الوسائل الاعلاميه الاخرى حاولت ان تثير
الموضوع يعني الموضوع ليس مفاجئ كان هناك
كثير من التلميحات اليه ولكن انت
الوثائق الذي نشر وال الطريقه التي قمتم
بالتحقيق فيها كانت مختلفه ما الجزء الذي
قلب
المعادله وكيف كيف اصلا بدا المشروع هل
كنتم فعلا تركزون على هذا الموضوع تحديدا
على الجواز الذهبي ام جاء الامر كما فهمنا
مصادفه اود ان اجيب على السؤال الاول اولا
وهو ما ما الذي كان يختلف في تحقيقنا نحن
اعتقد ان العنصر الحاسم والاساسي هو ان
قمنا بعمليه سريه مخفيه بحيث وصلنا ودخلنا
في اجتماعات ودعوات غداء مع هلاء الاشخاص
الذين قالوا انهم مستعدين على مساعده
مجرمين على الحصول على الجوازات وبالتالي
وكان اننا حصلنا على
تفاصيل كثيره وكبيره شرحوا لنا فيها كيف
قام بتنفيذ العمل وكيف كانوا يساعدون
المجرمين على الحصول على جواز السفر وهو
ما لم يحصل سابقا لدينا في الواقف الجزيره
ادله وصت مجموعه من الادله والوثائق في
شهر فبراير التي ادت سميت باوراق قبرص
وهذا الامر ادى الى هزه وصدمه لحكومه قبرص
ولكن عمل الخفي السري هو الذي السبب
الرئيسي الذي ادى الى التفاف الينا
والاهتمام ما قمنا به لان حضرنا اجتماعات
حر هؤلاء المسؤولون والذي كشفنا كيف كانوا
يقومون بذلك وانهم قاموا بذلك عده مرات
وبالتالي كان ايضا تشكل الفرق الرئيسي بين
تحقيقاتنا نحن والتحقيقات السابقه اما
سؤالك الاخر هو كيف ان بدانا التحقيق
الجواب النسيه والصريح وذلك هو ان لم نكن
حتى قريبين من قبرص بل بدانا في المملكه
المتحده كنا نحقق مسائل الفساد في المملكه
المتحده وكان وقمنا نفس الاجراءات وبدانا
بوضع شخص وهمي على انه يريد الصيني يريد
ان يستثمر اموال ولكن يحتاج الى جواز سفر
جديد لاخفاء هويته الحقيقيه هذا الشخص
بدوره
قدمنا الى ضابط الشرطه بريطاني السابق
الذي قال بده ان يستطيع ان يساعدنا وقال
يعرف شخص يستطيع ان يساعدنا ذلك الشخص كان
في قبرص وربما كان في اي مكان اخر لكن هو
قال ان رجله في قبرص وبالتالي جئنا ذهبنا
الى قبرص وبالتالي هذا قادنا بدوره الى
محامي وهذا بدوره قادنا الى عضو في
البرلمان بحيث وصلنا الى رئيس البرلمان
القدسي وان سرعه ما حصل كانت حتى بالنسبه
لنا مفاجاه ولكن كان امرا رائعا لان حصلنا
على مجموعات رائعه من الادله و وان ن ما
قمنا به هو يتفق معنا كثير الناس حصلنا
على ادله شديده
لورو الادله الشديده اللي كان يتحدث عنها
ديفيد للتو لا تخص قبرس فقط تخص الاتحاد
الاوروبي كله
كيف ان ما قامت
الجزيره امر رائع
جدا ذلك وضعوا كل العناصر اللازمه واعتقد
ان الامر كان حد شاهدنا اسوا ما كنا نتصار
نعرف ان كثير دول توجد هذه المشكله لكن ما
كشفه التحقيق الجزيره قبل يومين هو اكثر
بكثير ما كنا نتصور في يتعلق عن تضارب
المصالح والتدخل السياسي واستغلال السلطه
و وايضا انتهاك كبير لقوانين غسيل الاموال
و
وقبل تجار عقارات غير نزيهين وكل ذل هذا
التحق كشف كل ذلك واثبت ان هذا يحصل في
واقع الحال و وان ايضا هذا يبين انه ان
هذا ليست حاله استثنائيه ذلك ان اطراف هذا
الفيديو هذا التحقيق يبدو انهم كانوا
مستعدون
للعمل وانهم مطلعون تماما على القيام بثل
هذا النوع من الاعمال وان احد الاشخاص
القع قال شيء هو يلخص الامر كله وقال ان
هذا العمل هذه الخطه والبرنامج يعمل زمن
طويل وقال ليس هناك اي عمليه نح جوازات
نظيفه وهذا يثبت ان الامر ليس فقط مجرد
وضعه اشخاص بل هذا الشيء منتظم والامر لا
يقتصر على قبرص
بل فاليوم كان قبرص وقبلها كانت مالطا
وغدا ستكون دوره اخرى في الاتحاد الاوروبي
التي سيكش فيها مثل هذا البرنامج الجوازات
وبالتالي
القرار الذي اتخدته حكومه ق لتعليق واوقاف
ال بهذا البرنامج وهذا طبعا كان شيء هم
مضطرين القيام به ولا يمكن ان نمجده لا
نثني عليهم لهذا وبالتالي هذا هو الحل
الوحيد والواقع كان لابد ان يحصل منذ زمن
بعيد لايقاف هذا البرنامج للجوازات في
اوروبا كلها نعم يعني واضح ان يعني كانت
هناك محاولات في السابق 30 شخص كانوا قد
تم التحقيق معهم في هذا الموضوع قبل حتى
ان يعرض وثائق الجزيره ولكن ماذا بعد يعني
الان وقد تم ايقاف البرنامج كيف يعمل باثر
رجعي ماذا عن هؤلاء الذين دخلوا الى قبرص
يحملون الان الجنسيه وانتشروا في باقي مدن
وبلدان الاتحاد الاوروبي باسماء جديده
هويات نظيفه تماما بغض النظر عن نوع
الجرائم
التي ارتكبوها في بلدانهم ما الذي سيحل
بهؤلاء
هذه نقطه وجيهه جدا ذلك ان
فعلا الخطوات جرتها اتخذتها قص ليس لمصلحه
البلاد فقط ومواطنيها بل لكل الاتحاد
الاوروبي فقد شاهدنا كثير من الحالات مثلا
ما حصل في مالطا ان نقش الشخص روسي
اعتقلته السلطات
الفنلنديه لعلاقات شها ماليه وكان قد حصل
على جواز سفر مالطي برنامج جواز السفر
الذهبي في مالطا وبالتالي هذا يعني ان
الامر يهم كل الدول الاوروبيه وكل مواطنين
اوروبا وبالتالي هذه مشكله جديده وبالتالي
عناك مستويين والمشكله لابد هذه المشكله
ندرسها من جانبين في يتعلق بقبرص طبعا كل
الادعاءات وكل ما ادى الى التدخل السياسي
والقيام بالتحقيق اللازم فرض العقوبات وان
كل الجوازات التي منحت سابقا لابد من
اعاده النظر فيها وابطال مفعولها اذا
اقتضى الامر وكذلك ايضا سنح بعد اجراءات
على مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي ف فلابد ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يفرض عقوبات على كل
الذين قاموا باجراءات غير قانونيه وتؤثر
على اهداف الاتحاد الاوروبي وتؤثر حتى على
امن وبادئ التعاون بين الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي
طيبا شاهدنا انه اسمحي
لي نعم اريد اريد فقط حتى يعني نبقى في
اطار ما يحدث حاليا في قبرص كرد فعل على
ما تم نشره ديفيد سمعنا هناك غضب كبير في
الشارع القبرصي حتى خرجت مظاهرات تطالب
باستقاله رئيس البرلمان وما مسؤولين اخرين
حدثنا عن الاجواء الان في
قبرص
اعتقد انت استخدمت كلمه غضب وهه الكلمه
المناسبه فالناس فعلا يشعرون بغضب شديد
اذا هذه هذا الذي كشفناه وهم كان كانوا
يشكون بذلك منذ زمن بعيد وهذا امر يضر
بسمعه بلادهم وهناك ايضا غضب شديد لان هذا
اثر على سمعه وصوره قبرص وهم يفهمون هم
يرفضون ما تقول الحكومه بان ان ما اثر على
سمعه قبر ال تحقيقنا نحن وليس هم لان ما
يسي الى سمعه وصوره قبرس هو فساد
المسؤولين فيها ولا بد ان نقول انه كل
الناس الذي كشفناه في تقريرنا ينكرون ذلك
ولكن الشعب القبرصي لا يتفقون معهم فقد
اثبتوا خرجوا الى الشوارع عند البرلمان
ليله امس واليوم ايضا خرجوا الى الى
الشوارع و وهنا ايضا برلمان اخر بسبب تعقد
الاجتماعات برلمان بسبب الفيروس يعقدون في
مكان بديل وبالتالي الناس قد ساموا واحدهم
قال كفى كفى وكانت هناك دعوات لرئيس
البرلمان ان يستقيل تتذكرون هو لم يستقل
بل قال انه سيتخلى عن واجباته بانتظار
نتائج التحقيق نتائج التحقيق ولكنه لم
يفعل ذلك الا بعد الاسبوع القادم اذا فهذ
مفارقه كبيره فالرئيس حاليا في بروكسل في
اجتماع مع في اتحاد الاتحاد الاوروبي وهو
الواقع نائب الرئيس وبالتالي هذا اثار غضب
الناس اكثر ولكن الامر لم يدوا فيه هم
يرون انه لا ب المزيد من الاستقالات بل
حتى يمكن بعضهم يقول لا بد ان تشمل الرئيس
من نفسه بالفعل يعني مازق حقيقي الرجل
الذي يفترض ان يحل محل الرئيس متورط ويعني
اميط اللثام عن حجم تورطه بشكل لا يقبل
مجال للشك ولكن هناك عنصر ديفيد يعني يعني
نتحدث عن 7عه
مليار يورو دخلت للبلاد بسبب هذا البرنامج
برنامج الجواز الذهبي اكثر من 4000 شخص
حصل على هذا
الجواز هذا بالنهايه مدخول كبير يدخل على
البلد ما البديل الان يعني هل هناك تاثير
على اقتصاد البلاد بسبب ايقاف هذا
البرنامج متوقع
طبعا يا س نعم نعم هذا فعلا يشكل نسبه
كبيره من اجمال الناتج الوطني في قفز كما
قلت 7 ملايين يورو حوالي 8 مليار دولار في
هذه الحدود و هذا طبعا مصدر مالي كبير جدا
لدوله لديها مشاكل اقتصاديه هذا البرنامج
بدا في 2013 وادى الى واردات كبيره جدا
لكن النقاد يق انه ليس معقوله ان يؤدي هذا
البرنامج الى هذه المبالغ الكبيره علينا
ان ننظف برنامجنا ونستمر في لكن بطريقه
مفيده بحيث ان الاموال تذهب الى الشعب
قبرس لبناء وايضا لبناء المدارس والطرق
واقل من الاموال تذهب الى جيوب
الفاسدين نعم
الفاسدين ولكن اخرون يقولون لن ينجح ذلك
طالما سيكون هناك فساد وسيكون سوء استخدام
السلطه وبتالي لابد من الغاء البرنامج
تماما ولكن السؤال هو ما ينبغي ان تقوم به
الحكومه انها تحتاج الى بسياسه استثمارات
جديده للتعويض عن ذلك الحكومه تقول ستراجع
هذا البرنامج تعيد النظر فيه لكن ماذا
سيفعله لا نعرف ربما ستصدر نسخه جديده من
برنامج الجوازات هذه قد التي يقول الناس
عنها انها ستؤدي الفساد ايضا لكن اخرون
يقولون نسخه جيده صارمه من نفس البرنامج
يمكن ان تكون جيده وتخلق موارد جيده لقبرص
للاسف لم يبقى لي الا دقيقه واحده لور
بريو اقل يقول لي المخرج لور ما هي
الرساله او الدرس الاكبر اللي خرجنا به من
هذه التجربه
برايك ما هي الرساله الاكبر او او ما هو
الدرس الاهم من هذا الكشف اللي حصل من
خلال هذا
الوثائق ان هذا الموضوع اثبت انه في هناك
مثل هذه
البرامج قد تكون قابله للفساد ولسوء
الاستغلال لان العمليه هي عمليه سريعه
الحصول على
جواز خلال بضعه اشهر والكلف ليست مرتفعه
جدا ولا تطلب شروط سهله ليس بالضروره ان
يكون الشخص موجود في البلاد
وبالتالي وكل ذلك لجذب الاشخاص الخطا اذا
اردنا فعلا نقوم نقوم بعمل مشروع جيد فلا
بد نضع
برنامج يضع معايير اقوى ومتطلبات اكثر
وبذلك س شكرا ان ان رجال الاعمال ذو
الدوافع المشروعه سيكون مستعدون للمجيء
لور بريو من منظمه الشفافيه الدوليه في
بروكسل شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لديفيد هارس
زالت لدي الكثير من الاسئله ديفيد اريد ان
اسالك عنها انتظر لما تعود للدوحه ان شاء
الله ولكن اهنئك طبعا واهنئ فريق التحقيق
على هذا النجاح الكبير شكرا لك وشكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
ايضا